bei uns im Studio ist jetzt Bild tv-chef
Klaus Strunz Klaus wie ist deine Meinung
zu dem Thema findest du das eine
sinnvolle Maßnahme nein es ist natürlich
falsch falsch ich sage es bewusst
dreimal damit es auch jeder hört
diese Idee ungeimpfte aus dem Saal zu
verbannen auf der Tribüne zur Schau zu
stellen guck mal da oben sitzen die
ungeimpften das gehört nicht in dieses
Parlament und ich empfinde diesen zwei
Klassen Bundestag seit heute als Schande
wir haben ja den Bundestag uns auch
angeguckt den großen Plenarsaal es ist
ja eigentlich genügend Platz genügend
abstandsmöglichkeiten die man da
einhalten könnte also es gab ja auch
vorher schon eine Regel und der Wolfgang
Schäuble dem Parlamentspräsidenten das
war 3G 3G kennen viele wir alle auch wir
hier vom Arbeitsplatz und 3G ist die
richtige Lösung auch fürs Parlament denn
auch das Parlament ist ein Arbeitsplatz
also das bedeutet man ist geimpft
genesen oder legt einen Test vor ich
weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
fühle mich ehrlich gesagt immer noch am
sichersten in einer Umgebung von
getesteten Menschen wir alle hier im
Studio sind getestet sonst werden wir
nicht im Studio ob ihr geimpft seid geht
mich eigentlich gar nichts an und so
muss auch das Parlament funktionieren
und nicht mit einer Art
diskriminierungskampagne ungeimpften
gegenüber ich überlege mir auch was ist
die Symbolik also wer muss denn
eigentlich immer irgendwo anders hin ins
Eck muss der der was angestellt hat war
glaube ich nur noch früher so auf die
Strafbank muss man beim Eishockey wenn
man gespielt also es gibt überhaupt
keine positive Legitimation und was mich
im Prinzip am meisten aufregt ist
eigentlich finde ich sogar ganz schön
weil es offen liegt die
Unglaubwürdigkeit dieser Entscheidung
als Hauptargument nennen die
Parlamentarier nämlich man wolle die
ungeimpften schützen deshalb tun wir man
sie raus aus diesem gefährlichen Saal wo
ja geimpfte und gepustete Menschen
setzen um sie selber vor einer
Ansteckung zu schützen das ist in einem
Raum wir haben ihn ja vorhin angeguckt
wie dem dem Bundestag den Plenarsaal
natürlich an Absurdität nicht zu
übertreffen denn dieser Plenarsaal ist
quasi Open Air mit ich weiß nicht 100
Meter hohen Decken und einem riesigen
Platzangebot das bedeutet die
mitgelieferte Deutung dieser
Entscheidung lautet man muss geimpfte
vor den ungeimpften schützen und dann
sind wir sehr sehr schnell bei hier
unten sind die guten da oben sind die
bösen hier unten sind die vernünftigen
da oben für die Unvernünftigen da unten
sind die verantwortungsvollen da oben
sind die nicht verantwortungsvollen da
unten sind die gesunden da oben sind die
aussätzlichen und das ist etwas was
nicht in dieses Parlament gehört und ich
vermisse den Aufschrei zum Beispiel der
Liberalen warum wird denn dieses große
Thema der Freiheit jetzt wieder der AFD
überlassen die das heute wahrscheinlich
zu einem großen Schauspiel nutzen wird
aus meiner Sicht zurecht mit gutem Recht
weil es ein absurde Entscheidung ist wo
ist denn der große Liberalen Führer
Christian Lindner jetzt und sagt Leute
jetzt ist eine Grenze überschritten das
geht nicht in meinem in unserem in unser
aller Parlament das ist nicht zulässig
hier ist die Grenzübergang und es ist
jetzt das Parlament das wäre vielleicht
also für Zyniker wäre es das einzig
Positive dass man jetzt im Parlament
sehen kann wie dieses ganze Land
offensichtlich geordnet werden soll in
die guten die geimpft sind und die Bösen
schlimmen andere Gefährder die ungeimpft
sind das Ertrag ich nur schwer und ich
hoffe dass darüber diskutiert wird ich
hoffe sogar dass es Klagen gibt und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob die Justiz
zu einem anderen Urteil kommt das was
dann entschieden wird würde ich als
Staatsbürger sozusagen zur Kenntnis
nehmen aber wenn da rauskommt das ist
okay kriege ich noch mehr Zweifel
wahrscheinlich wird ja heute im
Bundestag sogar darüber diskutiert
werden 13 Uhr wie gesagt die Fragestunde
die erste mit Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
hier live auch bei Bild da wird
interessant sein zu beobachten wie die
AFD sich dann verhält ob die sozusagen
geschlossen auf die Tribüne geht in dem
Fall vielleicht sogar um die geimpften
nicht zu outen aber allein ich finde
allein diese Vokabel also im Bundestag
kann man sich jetzt so verhalten dass
man Menschen outet indem man wenn man
geimpft ist unten sitzen bleibt und nur
die ungeimpften und man muss also quasi
um eine Diskriminierung zu vermeiden
irgendwie Sachen machen ich meine wo
sind wir denn jetzt angekommen in dieser
Pandemie ich glaube inzwischen dass die
größte Folge der Pandemie nicht etwa
gesundheitlich und medizinische Themen
sind sondern die größte Folge der
Pandemie ist dass wir uns bewusst machen
müssen was ist zur verteidigen gilt in
unserer Demokratie nämlich die Freiheit
die Freiheit im Parlament ich meine noch
mal da kommen gesunde Parlamentarier die
haben nicht Corona sie zeigen einen Test
vor dass sie sozusagen negativ sind und
dürfen nicht in den Plenarsaal was kommt
denn da als nächstes der Alko-Test unter
der Wesensprüfung oder die
gewissesprüfung also irgendwo ist hier
jetzt sozusagen wirklich in Punkt
erreicht ein adventdepunkt und an diesem
Beispiel und das meine ich das ist ja
vielleicht sozusagen für Zyniker noch
das einzig gute daran dass man im
Parlament jetzt sehen kann was in den
Köpfen von Politikern vorgeht die diese
ausgrenzungspolitik verfolgen und
hoffentlich ist die Debatte die wir
heute auch zeigen werden dort wird die
wie soll ich sagen steil und mit aller
mit aller Kraft geführt und hoffentlich
wird sie auch mit einem liberalen
Momentum geführt und nicht nur von den
Seiten befeuert nun hat Philipp amttor
vorhin gesagt warum sollen für Vertreter
andere Regeln gelten als fürs Volk also
ins Restaurant komme ich auch nur mit 2G
oder zwei aber das Argument lautet wenn
man das Parlament in seiner ich habe da
vielleicht also ich habe eine riesen
Hochachtung vor dem Parlament für mich
das Parlament sozusagen der wichtigste
Platz der Demokratie und wenn man den
diesen diesen außergewöhnlichen Platz zu
vergleichen versucht mit etwas anderem
dann ist es der Arbeitsplatz und nicht
die Kneipe und deshalb muss gelten was
auch an den meisten Arbeitsplätzen gilt
nämlich 3G es hat auch gegolten bis
diese neue Parlamentspräsidentin von der
SPD sozusagen ans Ruder kam jetzt gibt
es plötzlich die verschärften Regelungen
und da wird mir doch Angst und Bange bei
der Arbeit wenn ich darüber nachdenke
was dieses Symbol für die corona-politik
dieser SPD geführten Regierung in der
Zukunft bedeuten kann nämlich dass wir
nicht zueinander finden sondern weiter
auseinanderdriften und die Tribünen wenn
man das angeschaut sind ja auch relativ
klein im Vergleich zu dem großen
Plenarsaal wie viel Platz ist da unten
gibt würde auch bedeuten dass die
ungeimpften auf dieser kleinen Tribüne
dann alle Platz nehmen genau und es wird
ja schon mal spannend sein wie viel
ungeimpfte gibt es da überhaupt und eins
ist ja auch je mehr ich darüber
nachdenkt dass du mehr rege ich mich
auch auf denn denkt man noch mal einen
Aspekt durch jemand kann sich nicht
impfen lassen wegen einer
gesundheitlichen Disposition
der wird jetzt ja auch da hoch verbannt
oder er muss offenlegen wahrscheinlich
ja also hat man dann so eine
armbänderung wo drauf steht ich habe
hohen Blutdruck und deshalb lasst mich
bitte hier rein ich meine das sind das
sind doch Zustände wenn wir über die vor
zwei Jahren geredet hätten und ich hätte
gesagt so wird es kommen dann hättet Ihr
zu mir gesagt pass mal auflegt dich
wieder hin ändert deine Medikamente du
bist verrückt wir sind in einer
verrückten Zeit im besten Sinne des
Wortes verrückt aus dem Bild gewandert
verrutscht und das muss sich sehr sehr
sehr sehr schnell ändern weil sonst
nämlich vollgeschäden lonkovic ist dann
eine ein vollgeschaden für die
Demokratie nicht für den menschlichen
Körper davor habe ich wirklich
Angst wir sehen hier die Fraktion der
AFD wie kriegt man das hin in dieser
Diskussion Klause dass man für die Sache
eintritt so wie du es gerade tust aber
gleichzeitig nicht in den Ruch kommt
Anhänger der AFD zu sein
jetzt achtung jetzt wird es
philosophisch da halte ich es mit
hafermass großer Philosoph großer Denker
der hat mir gesagt das wichtigste ist in
einer Debatte der zwanglose Zwang des
besseren arguments also das bedeutet
übersetzt wenn ein Argument in sich für
die Mehrheit der Menschen absolut
überzeugend ist dann hat es auch die
Kraft die Mehrheit zu überzeugen alles
was gekünstelt prich mein mein Hintern
auf meinem parlamentsstuhl mein Amt
retten wo man spürt das ist ein Argument
das hat nicht den zwanglosen Zwang
sondern das ist gekünstelt für einen
Zweck dem glauben die Menschen nicht
also setzen wir auf den zwanglosen Zwang
des Stärkeren arguments wenn jemand sagt
wenn du ins Wasser springst wirst du
nass
dann kann man da dagegen reden wie man
will man wird verlieren weil man wird
halt nass und das finde ich vermisse ich
in dieser Debatte dass die Argumente
nicht so überzeugend vorgetragen werden
wie sie vorgetragen gehören damit eine
Mehrheit sie hört aufnimmt durchdenkt
und ihnen dann aus freien Stücken folgt
das ist eigentlich eine Demokratie in
der ich leben müsste inzwischen leben
wir in der Demokratie wo ungeimpfte
verbannt und diskriminiert werden
unangenehm